my name is Dale Martin I teach in the
religious studies department and it's my
pleasure to welcome you to the Terry
lectures for fall of 2008 um the Terry
lectures were founded over 100 years ago
uh to deal with issues in science and
religion both sides of that dualism have
been somewhat broadly conceived over
different years um this year though for
these lectures these uh it's right on
target that this lecture will deal with
both religion a major religion Buddhism
and science itself so we're very
fortunate and looking forward to that
we've had a string of really good
speakers and uh we have some books
coming out that we think would be great
Barbara herstein Smith a couple of years
ago expert on Theory and literature and
epistemology her book has just been
delivered to the yel Press so you can
expect that Terry Eagleton lectures from
last spring on the Christopher Hitchens
Richard Dawkins uh debate about uh
atheism and theism uh has just been
delivered to the press and that will be
coming out before long and uh next
spring we will be having Marilyn
Robinson the author of the uh
prize-winning novel Gilead and she has
her another novel in a similar setting
called home that has been on the
bestseller list she'll be here in the
spring semester so we think we have an
exciting string of uh distinguished
lecturers with a variety of topics uh of
Interest
and so tonight it's my pleasure to uh
welcome Don Lopez to Yale I've known Don
Lopez for about 20 years I began
teaching at Duke University in 1988 and
Don's wife Tomo masuzawa who is a
theorist in religious studies was in the
religious studies department at the
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill just down the road Don who had was
just about to start teaching then at the
University of Michigan would be in
Chapel Hill regularly we all became not
only colleagues and regular dialogue
Partners on issues of religion and
culture we also became good friends
we've eaten many dinners together and
drunk much wine we've commiserated
together through many disappointing
political Seasons especially it seems in
North Carolina during the Jesse Helms
Dark
Ages but we've also vacationed together
on the beaches in North Carolina both
tomaco and Don are valued friends and
it's with real joy and affection that I
introduce him tonight Donald Lopez is a
son of Old Dominion the Commonwealth of
Virginia he took his undergraduate and
his graduate degrees from the University
of Virginia earning his PhD in
1982 he has taught for many years at
Michigan since 1989 actually and is now
the arus um Arthur's e link
distinguished University professor at
the University he is a scholar of
Tibetan Buddhism and Indian Mahayana
Buddhism he's also an expert in tibetan
studies more broadly and he has worked
closely at times with the Dal
Lama he has written several books on
Buddhism some very technical and
interpretive of uh texts some more
broadly ranging one of my favorite books
in all of religious studies as a field
much less just Tibetan Buddhism is his
book prisoners of shangra La Tibetan
Buddhism and the West this very
entertaining book shows how Western
Colonial forces came to disc
or in many ways create popular Notions
of Tibetan Buddhism but the book also
shows how Tibetan Buddhists themselves
have appropriated those Western Products
to turn around and present Tibetan
Buddhism in very popular ways back to
the West it's a fascinating study of the
modern constructions of religion and
religions within the colonialist and now
postcolonialist
projects Lopez is recognized
internationally as a distinguished
scholar of Buddhism Tibet and theories
of religious studies he's a fellow of
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences he has a new book that's coming
out very soon on the relationship
between Buddhism and Science and the
modern world and his Terry lectures will
draw on some of that material soon to be
published but his yell lectures will
push that investigation in New
Directions and offer new theories and
observations the theme of his four Terry
lectures is the scientific Buddha and
his lecture for this evening is
appropriately titled for reasons that
will soon become evident a purified
religion
Don thank you Dale for not telling any
more
stories it's a great honor to be invited
to deliver the Terry lectures and to be
the first lecturer to speak on the topic
of Buddhism and
science these lectures have a long and
distinguished history going back to
Dwight Terry's original request in
1905 and the detailed instructions he
provided in
1911 and the Terry lectures are
themselves part of a larger history of
endowed lectures on religion so both to
honor Dwight Terry and to place those
lectures in some historical context I
thought I would begin this evening with
a brief look at endowed lectures which
is actually an interesting topic
followed by a selective reading of the
terms of Mr Terry's indenture to
determine whether Buddhism and science
is in fact an appropriate topic for the
Terry lectures and I shall argue that it
is and to ask whether it is a topic that
is in fact long
overdue students of the history of the
study of Religion tend to think of the
famous lecture series as a product of
liberal Protestant theology centered in
the British Isles in the late Victorian
period but they are in fact much older
in 1672 during the reign of Charles II a
group of Presbyterians and independents
established what were called the
merchants lectures to quote uphold the
doctrin of the Reformation against the
errors of popery socinianism and
infidelity Robert Bole the Seventh Son
Of The Earl of cork in his will of
1691 designated funds to provide quote
an annual salary for some learned Divine
or preaching Minister who shall be
enjoined to perform the offices
following first to preach eight sermons
in the year for proving the Christian
religion against notorious infidels
atheists theists pagans Jews and
muhammadans not descending lower to any
controversies among the Christians
themselves in 1768 the bishop of
Gloucester founded the war Burton
lectures to quote prove the truth of
revealed religion in general and of the
Christian in particular from the
completion of the prophecies in the Old
and New Testaments which relate to the
Christian Church ESP especially to the
apostasy of
Rome but the late 19th century was
indeed something of a golden age in a
bequest in 1878 the duff lectures had
been established by the will of
Alexander Duff a Scottish missionary to
India that same year at the Charter
House of West Westminster Abbey
friederick MOX Mueller the leading
orientalist of his age delivered the
inaugural Hibert lectures endowed by the
Unitarian Robert Hibert who sought quote
the capable and honest treatment of
unsettled problems in Theology and in
187 in 1887 the will of Adam Lord gford
of Scotland established the gford
lectures they were be were to be devoted
to quote natural religion in the widest
sense of the term specifying that the
lecture is to be subjected to no test at
any time and may be of any denomination
or no denomination at all the first
gford lectures were given by Andrew Lang
one of the founders of of what would
eventually come to be called the
anthropology of
religion and uh in the United States
finally the hle lectures were
established to focus to on Middle
Eastern literature and its relation to
the Bible and Christian teachings these
were done by Caroline has in 1899 at
Overland
College which brings us to the Terry
lectureship on religion in the light of
Science and
philosophy Dwight Terry was not a Yale
alumnist or even a resident of New Haven
he was from Bridgeport and his request
specifies that quote the lectures be
repeated in his home City of Bridgeport
Connecticut and elsewhere at the
discretion of the
managers I'm hopeful this requirement
can be handled via
podcast it's clear from reading his
lengthy and eloquent request that he was
a Christian genuinely ecumenical in
spirit and convinced of the of the
ultimate compatibility of religion and
science and of the benefits to be
derived there from and so we read the
object of this Foundation is not the
promotion of scientific investigation
and Discovery but rather the
assimilation and interpretation of that
which has been or shall be Hereafter
discovered and its application to human
welfare especially by the building of
the truths of Science and philosophy
into the structure of a broadened and
purified
religion he continues the founder
believes that such a religion will
greatly stimulate intelligent effort for
the Improvement of human conditions and
the advancement of the race in strength
and Excellence of character to this end
it is desired that lectures or a series
of lectures be given by men eminent in
their respective departments on ethics
the history of civilization and
religion biblical research all sciences
and branches of knowledge which have an
important bearing on the subject all the
Great Law of nature especially of
evolution also such interpretations of
literature and sociology as are in
accord with the spirit of this
Foundation to the end that the Christian
Spirit may be nurtured in the fullest
light of the world's knowledge and that
mankind may be helped to attain its
highest possible welfare and happiness
upon this
earth like founders of other series of
this period Mr Terry insisted that the
lecturers quote shall be subject to no
philosophical or religious test and no
one who is an Earnest Seeker after truth
shall be excluded because his views seem
radical or destructive of existing
beliefs indeed he noted quote the
liberalism of one generation is often
conservatism in the next and that many
an apostle of true Liberty has suffered
martyrdom at the hands of the
Orthodox he thus welcomed quote
expressions of conviction from from
sincere thinkers of different
standpoints even when these may run
counter to the generally accepted views
of the day he asked only that the
lecturers are well qualified for their
work and are in harmony with the
Cardinal principles of this Foundation
which are loyalty to the truth lead
where it will and Devotion to human
welfare if we examine Mr Terry's bequest
as a historical text we see in it many
of the marks of liberal American
protestantism at the turn of the century
an ecumenical spirit
a conviction that religion or at least
Christianity is fully compatible with
science and that religion and science
can work together not so much to save
souls for the next life but to benefit
the Mind and Body in this one improving
the condition of humanity in many ways
it is a sentiment typical of a
particular optimism about religion
science and the future of the human race
in the years before the Great War the
perspective provides Ed by the passage
of a century might temper our own
optimism yet there is still much to
admire in Mr Terry's request reading it
today there's only one requirement that
betrays wild-eyed fantasy for he wrote
quote it is desired by the founder that
the lectures be marked by Simplicity and
clearness in thought and
style if it were possible for me to
speak with Mr Terry today I would
suggest to him that there already exists
a religion dedicated to helping mankind
to attain its highest possible welfare
and happiness upon this Earth a religion
that will greatly stimulate intelligent
effort for the Improvement of of human
conditions and the advancement of the
race in strength and Excellence of
character that this religion proclaims a
truth that both has been discovered and
shall be discovered Hereafter a religion
that is also capable of nurturing the
Christian spirit in the fullest light of
the world's
knowledge I would suggest to him that
the truths of Science and philosophy
have already been built into the
structure of a broadened and purified
religion I would suggest to him that
that purified religion is
Buddhism Buddhism is a religion that has
been described as both a philosophy and
as a science it is a religion whose
founder claimed neither to be a God or a
prophet of God but a man called the
Buddha this man through his own efforts
and his own investigations discovered
the most profound principles of the
universe and then compassionately taught
them to
others in his first sermon he taught
what are known as the four noble truths
first that life is qualified by
suffering second that suffering has a
cause third that there is a sensation to
suffering and fourth that there is a
path to
cessation this four-fold sequence
reflects the scientific approach of the
of the physician the Buddha identified
the symptoms he made a diagnosis he gave
a prognosis he prescribed a
cure the Buddha described a universe
that was not created by God but that
functioned according to laws of
causation indeed the most famous
statement in all of Buddhism is not a
profession of Faith but a summary of the
Buddhist teaching quote of those things
that have causes he has shown their
causes and he has also shown their
cessation this La of causation is not
limited to the material world but
extends also to the moral realm where
virtue leads eventually to happiness and
sin to suffering not through the whims
of a of a capricious God but through the
natural law of karma a law that unlike
the theistic religions offers an
adequate answer to the sufferings of the
innocent
child the Buddha understood the
operations of the Mind in precise detail
explaining how desire hatred and
ignorance motivate actions that
eventually result in all manner of
physical and mental
pain and he set forth techniques for
bringing the chattering mind and the
unruly emotions under control in order
to reach a state of
Serenity but beyond this he analiz the
merried constituents that together are
called the person finding among them
nothing that lasts longer than an
instant thus he discovered through his
analysis that there is no self that
there is no soul that what we call the
person is but a psychophysical process
and that the realization of this
fundamental truth results in a certain
Liberation the Buddha then extended this
analysis to the universe declaring the
universal truth of prati samut dependent
origination According to which
everything is interrelated each entity
connected to something nothing standing
alone with effects depending on their
causes with holes depending on their
parts and everything depending for its
existence on the Consciousness that
perceives
it yet whether wave or particle there is
no uncertainty about the ultimate nature
of reality which the Buddha called
shunyata or
emptiness the Buddhist discoveries were
not limited to psychological truths and
philosophical insights he described
multiple universes each with its own Sun
universes that arose out of nothingness
and returned again to nothingness over
the course of vast Cosmic phases of
creation Abiding and disintegration
phases measured in massive units of time
called countless
aons and he explained how countless
beings are born in these universes
during these countless aons each moving
through a process of spiritual Evolution
to a state of perfect
wisdom the Buddha discovered these
truths not through Revelation but
through investigation and Analysis
testing hypotheses in the in the
laboratory of his mind to arrive at
proofs he articulated these proofs in
his teachings the Dharma truths that
derived not from Faith but from the
Buddhist own experience and having
reached these conclusions he did not
declare them to be articles of Faith
famously telling his followers quote Oh
monks like gold that is heated cut and
rubbed my word should be analyzed by the
wise and then accepted should not do so
out of
reverence let me sit down there's some
seats down
here and when he died he did not Ascend
into heaven he laay down between two
trees and said to his monks all
conditioned things are subject to Decay
strive on with diligence then he passed
away like a flame going
out I would tell this to Mr Terry and
for support I would point to these words
of his contemporary Albert Einstein who
was developing the general theory of
relativity at the time that Mr Terry
made his bequest here are here are
Einstein's
words the religion of the future will be
a cosmic
religion it should transcend a personal
God and and avoid dogmas and
theology covering both the natural and
the spiritual it should be based on a
religious sense arising from the
experience of all things natural and
spiritual as a meaningful
Unity if there is any religion that
would cope with modern scientific needs
it would be
Buddhism this is Einstein's prophecy a
prophecy very much in the spirit of the
Terry bequest
it declares that the religion of the
future will not be limited to our small
planet but will Encompass the
cosmos all religions have sought to do
this but the implication here is that
the religion of the future will do so
accurately is cosmology based not on
fables but on
physics with scientific insight into the
nature of the cosmos the religion of the
future will dispense with the Primitive
notion of a personal God who created the
world and bestows rewards and meets out
punishments to his
creatures this religion will Encompass
both the spiritual and the natural in a
harmonious way it will require no
confessions of Faith or a sense to
propositions that derive from the
authority of scripture No rituals that
reenact forgotten myths it will have no
Dogma no church there will be no
damnation only salvation a Salvation not
through Grace but through experience the
experience of the individual sense of
Oneness with the
universe and finally it will be
compatible with
science this will be the religion of the
future but it is a religion that already
exists it is indeed an ancient religion
it is Buddhism set forth by the Buddha
the enlightened one over two Millennia
ago Buddhism I might again suggest is
the purified religion that Mr Terry
prophesied I might suggest all of that
to Mr Terry but I would not believe any
of it everything that I've just said
about Buddhism has been said many times
in the past but it is but one
perspective on a vast and ancient
tradition and it is it is a perspective
that is both limited and
limiting for everything I've just said
about the Buddha and Buddhism is either
partial or
misleading despite the sense of comfort
it creat creates indeed even this
commonly cited Declaration of Albert
Einstein appears nowhere in his writings
or records of his conversations it seems
he never even said
it but there is something about Buddhism
and about the Buddha that caused someone
to ascribe this this statement to
Einstein the Buddha of the Modern Age
and since the time when Einstein didn't
say this intimation of deep connections
between between Buddhism and science
have continued right up until
today so on May 25th of this year the
Sunday New York Times published an
article entitled superhighway to Bliss
about Jill bolt Taylor a neuroscientist
who suffered a massive stroke in
1996 after she regained
Consciousness and the ability to speak
she described the experience as
Nirvana the next day the article arle
was number one on the times list of most
emailed articles in the science times
section the following Tuesday there was
an article entitled Lotus therapy about
the growing use of the meditation
cushion to treat problems previously
consigned to the analyst
couch the next day Lotus therapy had
taken over the top spot as the most
emailed article two weeks earlier the
conservative commentator David Brooks
entitled his May 13th oped piece the
neural
Buddhists the Casual reader of the New
York Times during the month of May last
spring would likely have noticed this
and wondered why all the interest in
Buddhism and science all of a
sudden anyone working in the field of
Buddhist studies would have been
noticing this interest at least out of
the corner of the eye for some years now
in my own case I'd originally imagined
that claims for the compatibility of
Buddhism and science derived from the
60s gaining their first popular
expression in frit off's cpra 1975
bestseller the da of
physics it turns out that I was both
right and wrong the claims did derive
from the from the 60s but I was off by a
century statements about the
compatibility of Buddhism and science
were being made in the
1860s identifying the historical origins
of an assertion is the first step a
necessary but not a sufficient step
toward understanding that
assertion and it is significant that
claims for the compatibility of Buddhism
and science began in Europe during the
Victorian period as Buddhism became
fashionable in intellectual
circles similar claims for the
compatibility of Buddhism and science
began in Asia at the same time as
Buddhist
thinkers began to defend themselves
against the attacks of Christian
missionaries
thus to understand what the
compatibility of Buddhism and science
means today it's necessary to understand
what it meant a centy and a half
ago Buddhists first encountered science
perhaps Ironically in the guise of
Christianity it was a superior knowledge
a knowledge that Christianity possessed
and Buddhism did not thus providing yet
further proof of the superiority of
Christianity science served as a tool of
the missionary
and as a reason for
conversion later science would be
portrayed as the product of a more
generalized European civilization
something that the civilization would
take around the world the vehicle for
that Journey was
colonialism the modern Buddhists of the
late 19th and early 20th centuries thus
had good reason to claim science for
themselves whether to counter the
missionaries charge that Buddhism was
Superstition and idolatry
or to counter the colonialist claim that
the Asian was prone to fanciful flights
of mind and meaningless rituals of body
science proved the ideal weapon for the
Buddhists it was Buddhism in fact that
was the scientific religion the religion
best suited to modernity not just in
Asia but throughout the world it was in
Asian the Buddha who knew Millennia ago
what the European was just beginning to
discover this latter point was only made
possible through the strange
International Network that a century and
a half ago invented the Buddha whom we
know
today some even went so far as to
declare that Buddhism was not a religion
at all but was itself a science of the
Mind the implications of such a claim
become clear in light of the theories of
social evolution of the day which saw an
inevitable advance of humanity from the
state of primitive Superstition to
religion and finally to science if
Buddhism condemned as primitive
Superstition both by European
missionaries and Asian
modernists is in fact a science then
Buddhism jumps from the bottom of the
evolutionary scale to the top completely
bypassing that difficult category of
religion
altogether a century and a half later
missionaries have not disappeared but
their inroads into the Buddhist
societies are largely confined to to
specific time times and places of the
past Japan in the 16th century Sri Lanka
in the early 19th century Korea in the
late 19th century and European
colonialism at least in its classical
form has died out yet the discourse of
Buddhism and science persists unchanged
in so many ways the enemy is slain the
weapon continues to be
wielded the leading Buddhist voices over
the history of Buddhism and science have
been disperate coming from different
Buddhist cultures regarding different
forms of Buddhism as the most authentic
yet they also have something in common
some were patriots in the struggle for
Sri Lankan independence from Great
Britain others sought to prove the
relevance of Buddhism to the new
Republic of China yet others argued for
the essential role for Buddhism in the
expanding Empire of ma
Japan the inevitable links between
nation and science helped to explain why
today the most famous proponent for the
links between Buddhism and science is
none other than the Dal Lama who has
struggled for a half century for the
independence of Tibet perhaps still
seeking to demonstrate that Tibetan
Buddhism is not the Primitive
Superstition that the European
orientalists saw in the 19th century and
that the Chinese Communist Party saw in
the 20th rather Tibetan Buddhism is
presented as a worthy interloc of
Science and hence an appropriate IDE
ideology of a modern state that might
one day exist a free to
bet the implications of politics and the
discourse of Buddhism and science has
been ironically clear in recent days as
the Dal Lama has suggested that his
successor the 15th Al Lama might be
selected through a democratic election
prior to his own
demise while the avowedly atheist
Chinese Communist Party counters that
the traditional methods of De divination
must be followed to the
letter
but the question of Buddhism and science
is not merely a historical
question some may certainly choose to
see it that
way and feel able to confidently consign
it to the seemingly endless catalog of
products of European
colonialism however many of us may not
be satisfied with such an answer feeling
reluctant to see the links between
Buddhism and science as
anachronisms seeking instead to know
whether there might be some truth to the
old claims wondering whether there are
ways in which Buddhism and science might
in fact be
compatible yet to ask that question
raises a troubling thought if Buddhism
was compatible with the science of the
19th century how can it be compatible
with the science of the
21st if the Buddha long ago understood
Newtonian physics did he also understand
quantum
mechanics science has obviously made
huge advances over the past Century and
a half in every domain yet the claims
for the Buddhist preent have remained
persistent over this period furthermore
for the Buddhist the content of the
Buddhist Enlightenment however it's been
defined cannot
change it is it is an article of faith
in all of its various forms that the
tradition that we call Buddhism whether
it's a religion a philosophy or a
science can be be traced directly back
to the moment of the Buddhist
Enlightenment 2 and a half Millennia ago
how can Timeless truths be constantly
reflected in discoveries that have
changed and continue to change so
drastically over
time yet the claims for the
compatibility of Buddhism and science
have remained remarkably similar both in
their content and in their rhetorical
form this similarity has persisted
during major shifts in what is meant by
Buddhism and what is meant by
science in the early Decades of this
history Buddhism generally referred to
what European scholars dubbed original
Buddhism the Buddhism of the poly Canan
preserved in the terava traditions of
Southeast Asia andri
Lanka in the period after the second
world war although terava continued to
be regarded as Buddhism in some quarters
Zen came to the four in the Buddhism
science dialogue and since the 1990s it
has been Tibetan Buddhism that has
displaced s to become the chief
reference of Buddhism in the Buddhism
and science discourse largely through
the influence of the 14th
Alama the referent of science is also
often nebulous at times science has
meant a method of sober and rational
investigation with the claim that the
Buddha made use of such a method to
arrive at the knowledge of deep truths
about the inner and outer
world at other times science refers to a
specific Theory the mechanist
mechanistic universe the theory of
evolution the theory of relativity the
Big Bang whose antecedents are to be
found in the Buddhist
teachings at other times science has
referred to a specific technology the
microscope the telescope the
spectrometer that have been used to
discover what the Buddha knew long ago
without the aid of such instruments as
more precise instruments have been
developed over the past Century the
claims of the Buddhist knowledge have
remained constant
and it still other times science has
referred to the manipulation of matter
with dire consequences for Humanity
unless paired with the compassionate
vision of the
Buddha from the traditional perspective
the Buddhist truth is
timeless the Buddha understood the
nature of reality fully at the moment of
his Enlightenment and nothing beyond
that reality has been discovered or
could be discovered since that moment
from this perspective then the purpose
of all Buddhist Doctrine and practice
that has developed over the two past two
and a half Millennia is to make manifest
the content of the Buddha's silent
Enlightenment from the historical
perspective the content of the Buddhist
Enlightenment is irretrievable and what
is called Buddhism has developed in
Myriad forms across centuries and
continents with these forms linked by
the retrospective gaze to the solitary
Sage seated beneath a tree from either
perspective the traditional or the
historical in order to make this
Buddhism compatible with science it
would seem that the identity of the
Buddha and of what he taught must be
severely delimited eliminating so much
of what has been deemed essential
whatever that might be by the exalted
monks and nuns and ordinary lay people
who've gone for Refuge to the Buddha
over the course of more than 2,000
years if this is the cost there must be
a
benefit and this raises a question why
do we yearn for the teachings of an
itinerate Mican in Iron Age India even
of such profound insight to somehow
anticipate the formula of
Einstein I hope to be able to answer or
at least Advance this and other
questions over the course of three
lectures in those lectures it will be
necessary to use the word Buddhism many
times and so before I prev preview those
lectures for you I'm let me begin with a
disclaimer as a scholar of Buddhism I
realized that the history and complexity
of the various Buddhist traditions of
Asia and now of the West make it
impossible for me to use the word
Buddhism in a declarative sentence at
least without adding many
footnotes so in order to be able to
deliver these lectures it will be
necessary for me to dis disable the
alarms that go off in my head when I
speak such sentences this will allow me
to avoid performing that annoying mudra
of raising my arms in the air extending
the index and middle fingers and bending
them slightly touching the thumb to the
right ring finger rotating the wrist
clockwise and intoning the Mantra
Buddhism tomorrow's lecture will be
entitled building a better
Buddha in order for the Buddha to be
identified as an ancient Sage fully
attuned to the findings of modern
science it was necessary that he be be
transformed into a figure who differed
in many ways from the Buddha who had
been revered by Buddhists across Asia
over the course of many
centuries during the age of Discovery as
it was once called European scholars
divided the peoples of the world into
four nations Christians Jews mohammadans
and
idolators the Buddha was first
encountered by European missionaries and
Travelers as but one of many
idols and as an idol known by many names
it was only in the late 17th century
that the conclusion began to be drawn
that the various statues seen in sayam
cath Japan and Salon each with a
different name all represented the same
God and it was not until the 19th
century that it was known with certainty
that that God had been a man and that
that man had been born in India
by that time Buddhism was all but dead
in India and European scholars many of
whom never met a Buddhist or set foot in
Asia created a new Buddha a Buddha made
from
manuscripts this was the age of the
search for the historical Jesus European
philologists set out in search for the
historical Buddha and they felt they
found him this Buddha was portrayed as a
prince who renounced his throne who
proclaimed the truth to all who would
listen regardless of their social status
who prescribed a life dedicated to
morality without the need for God such a
savior held a special appeal in the last
half of the 19th century an appeal only
heightened by the fact that the Buddha
was not a Jew but an Arian it was this
Buddha unknown in Asia until the 19th
century who would become the Buddha that
we know today and who would become the
scientific Buddha
Mr Terry looked forward to the dawn of a
new religion forged from philosophy and
science a religion that will greatly
stimulate intelligent effort for the
Improvement of human conditions and the
advancement of the race in strength and
Excellence of character to this end he
asked that the lectures be delivered on
all sciences and branches of knowledge
which have an important bearing on the
subject all the great laws of nature
especially of evolution in the third
lecture then in keeping with Mr Terry's
request I will focus on the theory of
evolution and its compatibility with the
fundamental law of Buddhism the law of
karma in the first century of the
Buddhism and science discourse the
parallels between the doctrine of Karma
and Darwin's theory were repeatedly
proclaimed both in Asia and the West so
much so that Karma came to be described
by many as a natural law indeed it's
often been claimed that Buddhism is more
scientific than the abrahamic religions
in part because of its re retion of a
Creator
God which allowed it to avoid all
problems that attend creationism only
recently a Buddhist thinkers most
notably the current Dal Lama begun to
argue that the theory of natural
selection has profound implications in
fact negative implications that strike
at the very Foundation of
Buddhism so in this third lecture I will
examine the classical doctrine of karma
in some detail I will evaluate its
importance to Buddhist thought then I
will consider to what extent the Buddha
is threatened by Darwin this lecture
will include the postulation of a
materialist Buddhism one that does not
that one that does away with the mind
and matter dualism that lies at the very
heart of Buddhist thought I will will
then consider how much is lost in this
process having examined the past and to
some extent the present in the previous
lectures the last lecture will consider
the
future it will ponder the question if
there can be fruitful conversation
ations between Buddhism and science how
might they
proceed even to pose such a question
raises a host of issues issues of what
is meant by Buddhism what is meant by
science and how the flavor of their
fruit might be
measured bracketing these issues at
least for a moment I will examine the
most famous form of Buddhist practice
meditation this is the element of the
Buddhism and science discourse that is
most in the news these days and indeed
it seems different from what has come
before rather than pointing to
affinities between particular Buddhist
doctrines and particular scientific
theories research on meditation has
sought to calculate the physiological
and neurological effects of Buddhist
Meditation such research would seem to
introduce a welcome empirical element
into the Buddhism and science
discourse experiments are currently
being designed and data is currently
being gathered and that data is being
broadly interpreted
with some scientists seen more in it
than others my purpose here will not be
to assess these findings but to ask what
these findings ultimately have to do
with the meaning of meditation as it has
been traditionally understood and
practiced by Buddhists that is if forms
of Buddhist Meditation are shown to
reduce what we today call
stress what if anything does that mean
is there a danger in turning Buddhism
into a form of self-help
or has it always been in its own way a
self-help
movement regardless of these cautions
the importance of meditation in Buddhism
cannot be denied but rather than SE
seeking some form of clinical
confirmation of Buddhist practice
whatever form that might take it would
also be important to use neurobiology to
understand what happens in the
meditative
state with this data in hand we could
then turn to another essential form of
Buddhist practice the practice of
translation here however it would not be
the translation of Sanskrit into Chinese
but the translation of the clinical
description of Buddhist
Meditation into the traditional
descriptions found in the meditation
manuals composed over the
centuries as a very tentative foray into
this field in the final lecture I will
use the findings of split brain research
to consider one of the most fundamental
problems in Buddhist thought the problem
of the relation between Doctrine and
experience that is does doctrine
generate meditative experience or does
meditative experience produce
Doctrine I will conclude that lecture
and the series of lectures as a whole
with some final thoughts on why we ask
that Buddhism be compatible with science
and that science be compatible with
Buddhism of why we find comfort in
looking to the past to understand the
present and the future
I will ask what it would mean if we were
to conclude that Buddhism is in
fundamental ways incompatible with
science and I will ask whether that
would really be so bad thank
you thank you we have um plenty of time
for questions uh a couple of
announcements though there's a very nice
reception with different drinks that
will be set up on this level not that
level but right behind this theater uh
the pleas if you can the other lectures
in case you haveen noticed are on rather
odd days the second one is tomorrow but
it's at 4:15 not at night in fact all
the other Le will be at 4:15 and they
will be in room 102 not this room the
the final Le will be on Monday and
Tuesday of next week the third
announcement is uh we are recording this
and this will be put up online and that
sort of thing and so we must ask you to
please walk for the microphones to ask a
question or make a comment every time
someone sits down and says oh I don't
need the mic no the mic is not for you
the mic is for us so please walk to the
mic if you have a question or a comment
and Science and that's
right so the floor is
open
um we have heard about the uh word
Nirvana mhm has it been very clearly
defined like how can we parameterize I'm
a scientist so uh how can you describe
the state of Nana whether or not someone
achieved
it so
um Nirvana is a state that is understood
during life and then that one one enters
at death so there two types of
Nirvana uh so it said that when the
Buddha achieved Enlightenment under the
tree at age 35 at that time he his
insight into the nature of reality
destroyed all causes for future
rebirth uh all of his ignorance and
desire and hatred were destroyed
together with all the seeds of of his P
of seeds from past actions over all of
his billions of past lifetimes so from a
tral point of view what Nirvana is at
that point is the destruction of all
causes for future rebirth the person
then lives out his or her life at the
end of that life the person is said to
enter Nirvana what that means is that uh
the mind and body see SE cease to exist
so it's a state of the complete absence
of existence as we know it that is uh
the purpose of of the Buddhist teaching
is to put an end to the cycle of rebirth
so as you know according to Buddhism all
beings have been reborn countless times
in the past the idea is to put bring an
end to that cycle and when you use
insight into nature of reality that
destroys the seeds for rebirth so when
the Buddha died his Continuum of mind
which had gone on beginningless ended
and his body also ended so he was not
reborn so it's a state of of absence and
described traditionally as like the
blowing out of a flame the question is
where did that flame go so as as you can
certainly infer something like that has
been given multiple interpretations over
the course of the tradition but when we
look back at the earliest text it seems
to Simply mean the cessation of Mind and
Body
permanently hi so my question sort of
has two parts um in order to describe
something as scientific falsifiability
has been used as a Criterion right do do
you believe that Buddhism is falsifiable
and sort of secondly is that relevant
whether or not Buddhism is is
falsifiable right so the Dal Lama has
has wanted to introduce the principle of
falsifiability in into the study of
Buddhism uh and so he's been willing to
dispense with certain elements of
traditional Buddhist Doctrine for
example a flat world so the Buddhist
Cosmo cosm cosmography is of a flat
world with a central mountain and he is
said that that mountain has not been
perceived by photographs from the Moon
and therefore it does not exist and we
can dispense with that it has been
falsified however uh and what he said
was that we we do not rever the uh
Buddha for his ability for his his
skills as a measurer that is of the of
distances we rever the Buddha for his
ability to put an end to suffering so
there are two major doctrines in
Buddhism which the Dal Lama feels uh
have not yet been proved by science
these are Karma and rebirth and so he
makes a very clear distinction between
uh finding something not to exist which
is the case with the flat world and
simply not having found something yet
and it's his claim that science will
eventually find that rebirth uh and
Karma do
exist that they will be verified not
falsified if they're falsified Buddhism
has huge
problems yes sir
I I think of uh sometimes of Buddhism as
a uh kind of a reaction a a Reformation
of Hinduism to some extent sort of a
hacking away of all the uh murkiness
that had accumulated over the ages um
which some people could say about
Christianity itself in relation to
Judaism and uh in that regard um
reaction in science can be a distorting
factor right it can overemphasize
certain factors uh and uh to try to uh
counteract the the previous Trend and so
I'm wondering whether you could uh
perhaps see some of that in Buddhism for
example in regard to uh the the very
radical insistence on the idea U of the
unreality of the personality the
unreality of the soul and so on which I
think you could maybe analogize to the
idea that um well matter is made really
of matter is made of energy therefore
there's really no such thing as matter
it's really all energy you know that's
sort of a you know well it's kind of
true but it's really sort of a
distortion so I'm wondering if if if in
that case um that sort of insistence on
Buddhism might be coming out of that
kind of a reaction to Hinduism rather
than um something that would be more um
inclusive and uh less
reactive
well I'm not sure that Buddhism is
really a hacking way of Hinduism um
there there are many many things in
common and probably more than we we tend
to
identify um but I'm I guess I don't
quite see the connection to science can
you just say a bit more about
that well um I can cited examples where
um science has taken this turn or that
term a par time shift right and and uh
each one sort of causes its own
Distortion and likewise uh whether in in
trying to correct for the uh the
fallacies of the soul and the and the
person and so on that Budd Buddhism may
have
overcorrected and uh and sort of
distorted a a picture that could be
actually more detailed in the way that
our idea that that energy composes m
matter does not falsify the idea of
matter well this is a question that
comes up a lot in Buddhist philosophy
especially in the mam school and this
whole idea of ultimate truths and
conventional truths and the ability to
posit a functional Universe within this
deep idea of emptiness so uh it's a
major theme throughout the history of
Buddhist philosophy and um you know
whether Buddhism goes too far or not is
is sort of depends on how you feel about
Hinduism right so um
yes um first of all um I was Asen
Buddhist very Ardent and I'm still a
Buddhist but don't formally practice in
the uh Dharma room anymore but I have
had a very spiritual life and so um the
interface of religion to
science and you know the material world
in general is you know a pretty common
um question you might say series of
questions area of question
um for me I have no problem at all in uh
knowing that this plane is as
Shakespeare said merely a dream it is a
series of Concepts and
um
um to uh leave God
out I mean the Creator the actual the
original thought um is a little strange
for me I think that's just sort of like
trying to say that okay maybe he's not
an old man in the sky but he we
definitely had to have a beginning
somewhere and that was a one point and
in Zen it's you slap your hand on the on
the floor Buddha sat under the tree to
he realized his teachers the Brahman
teachers uh none of them had met Brahma
so his idea was to sit under that tree
until he either met him or died and he
clearly did meet him and um wanted to
share that brilliant idea which every
spiritualist anyone who's ever crossed
that line um wants nothing more than to
share it with other people and you
either get committed or um are allowed
to speak
um my feeling
in this context is that science is the
benefactor of
religion that um Buddhism as do do the
Native Americans as do any really
enlightened
person um the spirit knows the truth the
spirit contains the truth the spirit
will tell you the truth and the
scientists
um want so much to control control life
they often miss it they can't just sit
down with the microbe and say please
tell me what you are tell me what you
do um we create this world we this is
our
world we are the conceiver God gave us
power like himself we created this world
um I'm making more of a comment rather
than a question but you can whatever you
want take whatever you want out of what
I'm saying
um I'm very displeased with science I
find it ruled so much by money and
ambition and
um um fear mainly of failure fear of
what life actually is just as um
honestly I I wish that the enlightened
people the shamans would take over the
Sciences so that we could stop hurting
each other and creating more
um Mayhem and uh sort of terrible uh
inventions really
um okay
um I'm sorry I guess I don't really have
a question for you
okay in um in these many dialogues that
have been set up between the doy Lama
and scientists over the last 10 to 15
years there seems to be a l lot of
dancing around the what should I say the
presumed substance materialism or
substance monism at least right of the
scientists and the implicit dualism yes
of the Dal Lama and a Buddhism in
general corre and you've alluded to this
a little bit as you were setting up your
your future talk so I don't want to take
the uh the Thunder out of those talks
but it seems that the Dal Lama is also
encouraging this
belief that in some sense Buddhism and
science can be reconciled and I'm trying
to understand since they dance around
that
fundamental difference or
conflict um how he understands that
difference or whether it's glossed over
by everyone does he
understand the um dualism as adding
something that science is missing well I
mean you you I think understand the
question so I'm just setting that up
yeah yes so uh as I'll talk about in the
third lecture uh Buddhism believes that
there is mind and matter matter can
never become mind and and this is a
fundamental fact and if that if that is
not the case there are very serious
implications for Buddhist Doctrine and
practice the Dal Lama I believe feels
that the the existence of Consciousness
as understood in Buddhism will
eventually be identified by
neurobiology that is he feels that this
is one of these things like rebirth that
simply has not been found yet and he's
very very troubled by materialism and
and speaks out against it rather
strongly in his in his book about
science which is called the universe in
a single atom so I think you're right
that they Pro they tend to bracket that
fundamental issue in these
conversations U because most scientists
or materialists on that point and the
Dal Lama is is a strict dualist on that
point and that's not something that he's
willing to to give up anytime
soon I'll talk a lot about that in the
third lecture thank
you yeah kichi hi I first wanted to
thank you for this very beautifully
crafted lecture uh it was very
enlightening I I'm I'm again maybe I'm
anticipating too much but I felt that I
wanted to ask you this question part as
I listened to your lecture I kept
thinking you're basically
saying that this scientific Buddhism is
not really
Buddhism but then part of me sort of
said that maybe saying something
more um that actually Buddhism is not
one thing it's changed in different
times in different
places and that um this was one of them
MH and that uh it will change again and
so there is some kind of future for the
scient I just wondered whether I mean
obviously I'm sort of anticipating what
you um I'm asking for what you um are
going to tell us in future lectures but
that uh just as a kind of a general
orientation that um which way are you
moving
MH well um I guess there several points
that be made the first is that it's very
clear clear that this
uh Association Buddhism and science
begins at a very particular historical
moment we can identify that and
understand fairly clearly why that
happened um what's interesting to me is
that this claim has continued to be made
for over the decades as science has
changed so much and as our understanding
of Buddhism has changed a lot as you
know over that
time uh and so I think we can see how a
particular small group of generally
Elite monks mostly in Sri Lanka in China
and in Japan each responding to specific
historical circumstances in their
countries made this claim uh in order to
Champion their
Buddhism uh and as we know the vast
majority of Buddhists in those countries
and elsewhere in Asia had no interest or
knowledge of this whatsoever and the
irony is that Tibetan Buddhism was
completely locked out of that
conversation until just a couple of
decades ago when the Dal Lama became
interested interested prior to that time
Tibetan Buddism was lamaism it's
Superstition it's not really Buddhism so
the fact that it's sort of moved to the
four is quite interesting as we look at
this process so I think part of the
issue is simply to to to give a history
of this and there's there's a value in
that I think uh the question then is how
do we understand this uh I think from
the point of view of Buddhism that is uh
we know that um Buddhism has assimilated
the the the Hindu Pantheon in the heaven
of the 30 3 we know that the uh the
fierce deities of Tibet have become
Dharma pao's protection of the Dharma we
know that the Kami have found their
place in the mundela so does science now
somehow have to become incorporated into
Buddhism as Buddhism spreads to the West
that is I think again if we look at it
as the evolution of of Buddhism uh and
and the local Gods finding their place
in the pantheon does the god of science
somehow have to become a bodh SAA yeah
yeah yeah
but go back
to uh go back to one of the things you
started with and that Paradigm for the
four noble truths is based on medicine
right and in the Buddhist early Buddhist
text and later Buddhist text they're
constantly calling the Buddha a doctor
doctor right so don't they start making
Buddhist Buddhism
scientific well do you want to call
traditional Indian Medicine Science I
mean that's of course well that was
their science sure MH yeah so
that certainly the metaphor of the
doctor the great physician goes way way
back that's very true but again part of
that part of that metaphor is that he
teaches what is appropriate uh to each
person he doesn't prescribe the same
cure for all maladies and that fits
right into this idea of does he somehow
then incorporate science in order to
bring people to the Dharma who find that
somehow attractive right and he also
takes some of that from the medical text
right yeah
yes
sir yes sir perhaps 30 or 40 years ago I
read a book by uh an man who had been an
English cleric who came to this country
and wrote a number of books on Buddhism
and the one thing I remember is that he
said
Buddhism for him was closer to Western
Psychiatry than Western religion I
wonder if you would say something about
that that was the kind of thing that was
said 30 or 40 years ago that was that
was part of the Buddhist Buddism and
science dialogue people primarily
reading DTI Suzuki the great uh sort of
proponent of Japanese and Buddhism and
looking at that in terms of
psychoanalysis Eric FR and others were
became interested in that so um the
whole use of Buddhism uh for things that
would typically be given over to the
psychiatrist that's continued to to go
on and people are using meditation for
all sorts of uh sort of psychological
problems
so yeah they both were trying to
cure our difficulties sure it depends on
how you define difficulties but
certainly at that level that one could
say so yes yeah okay sorry yeah do you
think what determines what is science
and what determines what is Buddhism is
culturally determined that it depends on
certain
markers uh certain signs certain
communities
uh certain uh uh allegiances Etc
definitely yeah how will that contribute
to your methodology in the upcoming
lectures so when I talk about science so
Professor granos has just mentioned of
course there was this long tradition of
of of Indian medicine and and
traditional science but I'm using the
term science in these lectures to refer
to the Western science that was
introduced into Asia during the colonial
period And so we're looking primarily at
the mid 19th century and after and how
science changed during that period now
Buddhism also changes radically during
that time and what we mean by Buddhism
is something that is very difficult to
identify because up until we all we have
Tibetan Buddhism Japanese Chinese all
all of these which only sort of begin to
gather a certain sort of single identity
during the colonial period so it's very
important as you say to look at the at
the given moment and what Buddhism and
science mean at that point and today
science basically means neurobiology and
Buddhism means meditation and so that's
I'm going to end with that but I want to
show how we got to that point over the
past Century and a half that's the
temporal component I guess I'm I'm
interested in the spatial component that
is across different cultures and regions
there seems to be an assumption that
science is the same for each and every
culture nowadays is it really in the
same way that we uh seem to most people
would acknowledge that Buddhism is
probably different for uh different
cultures that practice it as a sort of
one of their dominant religions um I I
would tend to think that in the popular
imaginations there is a consistency to
what people understand by science and
it's not as as varied as what people
mean by Buddhism you know thank
you you sort of alluded to this in your
in your answer but you've said some
words on the the value to Buddhism of
incorporating science could you you say
a few things about the value to science
of incorporating
Buddhism uh I'm actually not sure what
the value to science is of incorporating
Buddhism I think that's something that
we can we can explore but um that's
largely been a claim that's been made to
exalt Buddhism above Christianity and
other religions and I'm not sure that's
all that useful ultimately we can see
how it was important in colonial times
now it seems less important to me yeah
so you're not saying it's not useful I
mean I don't know do you think it's not
useful so science the the use of Budd
how would Buddhism be useful to science
I'm asking yeah um of course it depends
what you mean by Buddhism but um nothing
is appearing to my mind immediately on
that point
yeah yeah hi hi um I was just wondering
if when I hear people talk about the
intersection between science and
Buddhism um immediately comes to mind is
is what you touched upon which is faith
and how um at least American
americanism um sort of glassed over
faith and made it about meditation but
certain kinds of Tibetan Buddhism you
know Guru worship worship and devotion
and I was just wondering if um the PE
the scientists who are examining
meditation Buddhism how are they
approaching devotion and faith and
especially with the
guru well the interesting thing about
most of the research that's been done on
Buddhist Meditation is that the the
science scientists have been Buddhists
that is they are Western Buddhists who
have are long practitioners of of Theus
of meditation and other forms of Tibetan
Buddhism so
uh one of my points is that all the
things that you talk about the guru yoga
very 95% of Tibetan Buddhism 95% of all
forms of Buddhism some have to get
bracketed away and not be Buddhism in
order to be compatible with science and
so there's a major loss there obviously
but one of the problems that's I think
been
present in early meditation studies is
that uh the scientists have been Zen
practitioners vusa practitioners who
have been who've known what they've been
looking for before they start yes
sir I I'm thinking of the the wonderful
history of of dialectic and and debate
internally in Indo Tibetan Buddhism and
this this this willingness to develop
new synthesis you know taking in the the
middleway school and the
mind only school and then shantak comes
back and takes the earlier schools and
brings them back in and and I'm I'm
wondering if if given that the the
history of um the importance of
epistemology and Buddhism going back
like the seventh century and this
willingness um and I'm remembering your
book on the heart Sutra this willingness
to just say there there are no scas
there are no Four Noble Truths and to
move forward from there and and whether
that might give the platform for for
relating with science yeah I mean so the
whole debate process in Tibet as you
know is is meant to sort of hone a
certain kind of intellect but uh
certainly The Debaters in the courtyard
of the among the gukas would say that no
matter how good or bad or debater you
are mamaka is best that is if you if you
if you can't prove the mam point it just
means you're a bad debater it doesn't
mean that you've found some synthesis so
there's a very strict hierarchy of
philosophical views at least in gupa and
um they really feel that you know that
that cannot be challenged ultimately
because that's the way things are and so
the whole question of synthesis is
really more of a historical thing and
the the Tibetans many Tibetans that the
guka school would say shant R to in his
synthesis was simply wrong right so yeah
you're speaking to a yeah okay all right
yeah yeah um my question might kind of
come from a place where I'm assuming
there are places Buddhism is untouched
and kind of hoping that there are places
that are still not fully globalized how
much do you think Buddhism is really
gonna get from making itself a part of
science maybe you touched on it and I
just kind of missed it but how much is
that religion really going to get from
bringing itself into the Western
Scientific
culture well uh so far it's gotten to
the point where many people think that
Buddhism is compatible with science I
mean it's it's become something of a
trism to to make that claim and many
people feel that Buddhism is the best
religion because of that and so I think
a good deal of the uh the positive view
that we have in in American culture
European culture about Buddhism comes
from this this scientific dialogue
that's been going on for 150 years but I
think I'm going I want to argue in the
end that uh Buddhism actually loses a
lot in this process as well and I'm
going to say that it's uh it's it's too
high of a price to pay
you mentioned the issue of
falsifiability and I was wondering if
you can comment on uh how Buddhism and
science the relationship there is
affected by modern scientific cosmology
and specifically the big bang and the
current interpretation which is that the
Big Bang is not a cyclic phenomenon
right well it certainly is a cyclic
phenomena in in Buddhism um and so the
Dal Lama has has said that in Buddhism
it's not just one big bang but many big
bangs and you can tell me whether he's
right you're wrong about that well
science can make a measurement that says
no it's not it's a current understanding
right well again the Buddhist can always
say sooner or later you'll find out that
we were right
um you can do with that what you will
yeah
right
yeah you mentioned uh mind into matter
or matter into mind was wondering what
you meant by that what is that and also
if you have ever practiced Buddhism or
meditation
yourself uh well to the first question
um Buddhism uh believes that uh there is
consciousness and that each one of us uh
is our our body uh is the container for
a a stream of Consciousness that has
gone that goes back without any
beginning that is in Buddhism there's no
creation uh there the cycle of rebirth
is
beginningless and so uh you are a series
of moments of Consciousness that go back
forever and will continue Forever Until
you achieve Nirvana so Nirvana is simply
the cessation of that sequence of
Consciousness so it's very important
therefore in Buddhism that that mind
comes from mind mind does not come from
matter and Consciousness can therefore
not be produced from matter but is is uh
substantially different from matter so
that's the that's the answer and I have
tried some meditation
yeah okay I'm going to uh break this now
for our Refreshments um I thank you very
Don I have one more comment though
before you applaud for Don I I just want
to encourage you to come back uh there
are always people who come to these
lectures who've not been regulars of the
Terry lectures uh much in the past and
so I don't for if you're in that
category I don't want you to get
frustrated by something that often
happens uh which is we're always
debating about what we we mean by
science and exactly what somebody means
by do for example is Hippocratic
medicine from the ancient Greek world
does that count as science well we might
say it did for the Greeks would it count
for modern science well we might not
that's part of this the fun of these
talks is that although the general topic
of religion and science uh is steady the
individual topics vary widely but we
often keep coming around to what do you
mean when you mean when you say
Christianity as we did in the Terry
Eagleton talks there were people who
thought that Terry Eagleton was just
meaning something different by
Christianity than what they thought and
we do that with science too so don't get
frustrated with these kinds of questions
because that's actually goes to the nub
of some of these lectures so thank you
Don for helping to raise
[Applause]
[Music]
that